IT IS TIME TO PLAY DISENGAGED.
DISENGAGED.
EVEN I'M NOT THAT (BLEEP)ING
EXCITED ABOUT THIS.
THAT SEEMED EXTRA OVER THE TOP.
I'M MEAN, I'M HAPPY BUT --
(AUDIENCE MEMBER WOOS)
NO.
THE TUMBLR BAD ENGAGEMENT
PHOTOS COLLECTS SOME OF THE
WORST NUPTIAL IMAGES EVER
CAPTURED.
BUT FOR WHAT IT'S WORTH, IT'S
OBVIOUS THAT THESE GROSS
WEIRDOES BELONG TOGETHER.
COMEDIANS I'LL SHOW YOU A BAD
ENGAGEMENT PHOTO AND FOR 250
POINTS YOU'LL GIVE ME THE
COUPLE'S CAPTION.
>> FIRST UP, HOW ABOUT THESE
PARK BENCH LUCHADORES.
BRENT.
>> PELASE JOIN US AT THE MOST
TERRIFYING WEDDING YOU'LL EVER
BE AT.
>> Chris: POINTS. STEVE.
>> ONCE OUR GREEN CARDS COME
THROUGH WE CAN TAKE THESE MASKS
OFF.
>> Chris: POINTS TO STEVE
RANNAZZISI.
NEXT ONE.
HOW ABOUT THIS CLASSY GESTURE?
THAT IS THE WEDDING SHOCKER,
APPARENTLY.
STEVE.
>> MAN WITH VAGINA FINALLY FINDS
LOVE.
>> Chris: POINTS.
JESSIMAE.
>> THAT IS ACTUALLY ME FLASHING
THE SHOCKER BECAUSE MY JAILBIRD
HUSBAND GOT SENTENCED TO THE
ELECTRIC CHAIR.
>> THAT'S JUST A JOKE. IT IS NOT
REAL!
>> Chris: NO, NO.
>> IT IS NOT REAL!
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
>> Chris: JESSIMAE, THAT WAS
GREAT.
I AM GIVING YOU POINTS.
I DON'T CARE WHAT YOU GUYS SAY.
SHOCKER, ELECTRIC -- OH,
PERFECT.
NEXT ONE THE CAPED CRUSADER AND
HIS THE BLUSHING BRIDE.
>> OH, BOY.
STEVE.
>> BATMAN RESCUES PUSSY FROM
TREE, RIGHT?
>> Chris: POINTS.
JESSIMAE.
>> WOMAN MARRIES MAN WITH SOUL
PATCH, THINKS HE IS BATMAN,
WOMAN STILL MISSING.
FAMILY JUST WANTS HER BACK.